robert spencer idf chief of staff
lieutenant general aviv kahave
is in washington right now and he's
warning the biden
administration about well
nuclear weapons coming out of iran and
here's the quote
from the general iran can decide that it
wants to advance to a bomb either
covertly or in a provocative way
in light of this basic analysis i have
ordered the idf to prepare a number of
operational plans
in addition to the existing ones we are
studying these plans and we will develop
them
over the next year that's from kohavi
will israel attack iran alone if
necessary
if necessary absolutely israel
understands
that it can't trust biden's handlers
biden's administration is full of haters
of israel
uh as a matter of fact the biden
administration at the height of the
recent conflict
between hamas and israel sent hadi armor
over to israel to try to make peace
and hadiyama was an open supporter
of the palestinian intifada while he was
in college he has shown no signs
of having moderated his views and yet he
was appointed to a high level position
in the biden administration
and was chosen by biden sanders to be
the one to go to israel
this was practically a deliberate and
open
explicit insult to the israeli
government it was essentially a tacit
signal
that biden's handlers were saying we're
on the palestinian side
here so you can't expect anything from
us
and you cannot continue to resist
the palestinian jihad well israel
obviously can't accept that
because it would be tantamount to
committing national suicide and so they
understand
that this is now the crunch time and
they have to act on their own
you